gay way bro you ain't gonna go hard on
my pants like that
i'm just proud of the company that makes
those
that those hold up at the hinges then
what did you tell them
what you told them i said you have
exactly 73 cents in your pocket
[Laughter]
no yeah man they're great oh and they
feel great man they look are they really
that tight yeah
there's tighter than your other you have
black ones too right there's tighter on
the thighs
listen yeah you're talking a guy i dude
these are my ride or dies they're
starting to fall apart they're
so thin i know those are your
ride-or-die oh dude i i got these when i
first started doing stand up so these
are
five six years old oh i have more
pictures of these on stage than any
other gene
there was some history i sent them to
the taylor that's why like all this is
they didn't come like this this is real
oh [ __ ] dude remember when they tried to
come out with
like the whole athletic athletic genes
what you mean like uh i think it was
levi's joggers no
they tried to come back for people with
athletic legs yeah they call it
yes guess who bought into that me dude i
did two
joe rogan oh he did and still best what
yeah he'll always be like dude you
didn't get you some of these bar
and like they started doing her like
yeah they were like yeah the
barbells i'm like nine where's that
those are trash
yeah they suck dude he loves them though
yeah he swears like
i don't know that i mean for me like my
legs
my bill g-star is the best g-star star
yeah because they're
they're they're stretchy enough bobby
schmidt tight enough
yeah i was wearing it before bobby
schmurger he's also in prison yeah
they're like three thousand trailer
repair huh three thousand
i don't know they're pretty expensive no
like two hundred bucks 180 yeah
for a good pair of jeans dude seven yeah
they wanna pay like 150 for these
i'm telling you man i make run g-star
g-star if i make one false move these
are
gonna
completely rip off do they make this
style anymore
uh yeah yeah i just got some black ones
i was at the mall where uh billy eilish
filmed their video
oh that's the americana or something the
galleria americano
because americana is the outdoor one
right across the street is the galleria
yeah
uh because billy eilish has a new music
video there yeah
and i looked it up where it is i'm like
oh [ __ ] that's that galleria and then
we're like oh we haven't been there
forever we should go it's a dope moment
we bring the family best small
in california i think you talk about the
one in glendale but not a lot of people
go to
i don't know why like i'm just i swear
to billy america
i'm sure people did what we did because
my son loves music videos yeah so her
new
video came out he's like where's that
damn like that's the mall dude and he's
like where i'm like i don't know look
i'm like oh [ __ ] it's right up the
street really
so we went to it it was packed and i was
like man i bet billy isle is shooting a
new video here mustard
people must have googled the same [ __ ]
cause it was packed what do you mean by
like you got these
no i don't know i got these like
probably in denver if it's that long ago
yeah i know i got these in santa monica
third street
my buddy tried to show me jonah hill's
pants he got some for big
boys but he's tiny why would we listen
to him
i don't know what johnny hill that's
true he's not tired no he's not
he's getting away oh jonah i'm sorry i'm
thinking of
joe jonas jonah
but also jonah hill's not a big dude
he's big again
and he's big again
he just had a collaboration oh he's yeah
you know he's got that short fat dick
he's small oh really feel like a
stingray damn jeans are tough for us big
dudes
look he got it back jonah hill or joe
jonas jonah jonah
and he just did a collaboration with
adidas he got his own shoe yeah he's got
his like no he don't you know he has
some swag
yeah he's really sweet i think does he
looks so good in that photo i hate him
when he got all skinny i know i like to
promote health but dude
i'd like to promote health like if chris
farley got all skinny when he was alive
you'd be like dude what the [ __ ] that
even funny
you promote health unless they're funny
right yeah can you stay with it dude
yeah look at this see oh he's a small
dude yeah his legs are different i'm
telling he's not
who's the dime piece next to him is that
clint eastwood
playing eastwood look at that diamond
who is that who's that
i don't know but jonah hill's not a good
guy to model your jeans at all what's
the point of all this conversation i
don't even wear it
he's small i don't know who to model off
of her jeans look at those shoes right
there oh you know you know your similar
body
uh jerry from chair oh
yeah that's from basketball yeah yeah
shout out to baseball
um i always do that when someone brings
up uh jerry i go
that's chappelle's boys like
every time i don't even know that the
cheer mates i don't know the guys
the same body type though same vibe
right same vibe no
body type that's what i'm saying like
your bodies are the same oh yeah
he's a thicker one man i'm yeah i don't
know who to model
no he's a little he's definitely heavier
i don't oh yeah because like he's much
more like top
heavy like he's kind of gonna if you
wanna if
yeah that dude is [ __ ] j just
has some tits on him yeah man he was
standing there
let me see jerry i feel like you and
jerry are similar man you kiss my ass
let me see they got the same kind of oh
yeah yeah i see you dude
let me stand like that right he went to
harvard
no no navarro yeah let's get some
glasses though
no he wouldn't no no he went to pelican
bay right there that's right
let's see what he did
yeah but when you were walking and
saying the mom like [ __ ] if [ __ ] like
you were walking down forgot my spell's
pretty jacked
like if you got like like yonder like
dead left and eat right you'd be [ __ ]
huge should i do some dead lifts then
all i have i mean
i did i just had the kettle bell yeah i
got deadlifts at the house
it depends if you want to be jacked you
know i should i should get another one
and i could probably
you do something so do some stuff that
way yeah yeah that guy is [ __ ]
jacked jb buckley all natural
yes he also works at cvs he doesn't work
in on cv he does
he works at cvs when kanye west made a
music video of him knocking that dude
out he was an employee at cbs
are you serious welcome to the ufc
fellas damn
insane right he won this weekend too
shout out
wait what did his legs look like
walgreens is awkward oh walgreens
i think cbs owns walgreens
the same [ __ ] it's all the same
i didn't yeah but he's jagged i don't i
got to see people's legs
yo that kick was amazing then he
followed up and beat that uh guy from
louisiana
yeah yeah that guy was undefeated dog
can we talk about
jelly roll in nashville our liaison of
nashville yeah
what's up on friday night yeah great
dude that that green room was lit come
on man
come on liddy like a titty oh my cat was
back there
the whole squad was back well you got to
tell the audience earlier that day we
watched six nine documentaries so we was
already on some rapper [ __ ]
oh yeah we watched the the takashi 69
documentary this is a documentary
six nine like a history of daniel
hernandez yeah on hulu yeah it's a great
documentary i want this to be
on record i'm a huge fan now do you want
you want things to be already
sure gateway
but we watched that so we were lit and
then jelly roll got in there
making everybody do shots oh he was
turning people
up he came with like he said y'all smoke
he gave me y'all like what
he the friends totality whenever you
when it whatever we asked for he came
through oh he came in
merch came through go to the video where
he's singing
they love him out there oh he's a big
deal he's a big deal out there
his music videos get millions and
millions yeah
how about you wrote this on the spot on
the spot bro hold up
you know i call my son bubba both my
kids bubba and he calls everybody bubba
it melts my heart
oh yeah [ __ ] love jelly
yeah i'm good he needs to come out here
and come hang with us straight up
we're gonna go to one of his concerts he
said i can see
this sunday morning
[Applause]
it's sunday morning
it's such a vibe check out his off-white
flies too
how about he had a his dime piece wife
come drop off his watch
i didn't see his wife i didn't see it
either but you showed it to go to her
chin
she's the only fan hey
how about how about him just like
showing
he was like yo you see my wife bubba i
was like nah and then he showed us a
picture of her
all her sexy photos i kind of got
aroused but i didn't want to get aroused
by him because
that's just you know that's your queen
he's like bro you don't park a ferrari
inside a garage you show it off i said
it makes sense that makes sense great
dude
man i love him
yeah we went when we went to go get my
hair cut he was like hey let me know if
y'all good take my number down
yeah and they knew i'm at the barbershop
they knew him at the barbecue dude this
is what kind of guy jelly roll is his
car his truck is his big ass truck which
he [ __ ] up when he's
uh driving me around um he uh his
someone jacked his truck oh yeah the
story of this story he's gonna instead
like in his wife called the cops and
stuff but you know
jelly runs nashville he called a couple
of the boys the nice little boys
and he said when this this young kid who
doesn't know who he's [ __ ] with
there's his girlfriend
look ridiculous anyway
so he said uh caught some of his
nashville homies
and the dude who was a young kid who
didn't know their [ __ ] jelly roll
he was gonna bring it to the chop shop
when he pulled up the dude was like oh
no no no but dude
that's jelly roll's truck and the kid
was like what he's like mm-hmm
we're not taking it he goes you knew so
the dude called up jelly was hey
your truck's missing the kid he did he
didn't know it's right here
and then the cops came and uh jelly will
walk the house like we don't need you
guys
and like why he's like it's coming back
now false alarm don't worry about it
like that's the power of jelly roll
power yeah it was at the barber shop and
it was like all hooded out
and then uh he was hiding his rolex
i think it's funny that not so much but
justin when we're on the road like
when we're eating at that uh one of the
natural chicken hot spots
there's just a black dude ordered his
hat on justin kept staring at him yeah
he's i
don't know i was like dude you just
ordered are you
racially profiling right now how are you
sharing racial profiling yeah
he's just ordering food chilling dude
he's like i don't like them around here
yeah
like now you you see leo like britney he
didn't like it outside
where we were at for the barber shop it
was pretty good but seems like tyrone
bigham's off chappelle show he's like
man
a little too dark you look around like
they're too good for me it's a little
hoodie for me they didn't even want to
stand outside to wait for the uber
that's a lie i was
listening to him wait can i tell my
story can i tell my story tell you
chabelle and justin went inside the
barber shop by the way it's like 12
8 black guy as soon as we get into the
barber shop by the way it was great it
was great it was cool you know i'm used
to it so it's in the shop and you start
talking about lebron
well well listen they had me like like
the barbershop sports talk
it was a pretty lit barbershop it was
but this is a little it sounds fun well
we get outside i go outside to talk to
this one it's always one guy who's not
cutting hair he's like who are you here
for i'm break
unbreak always on board that's the one
you never go to no because he's
the reason why he's on break thank you
so he's like who y'all hit phone and i
was like well chappelle here for
somebody and he was like i'm here for
such and such
so him and justin get outside go inside
me and the you know
the guy we building up rapport he was
like yo you got a nice watch on oh you
[ __ ]
i just did this i just did i just put it
on my yeah i just covered it a little
bit
right so i stayed outside the whole time
talking to i don't know why you look at
us
i don't know why you're looking at him
like that bruh so look let me tell my
story
so so i had my hand over the thing the
whole time you know on my wrist
so i go inside the barber shop chappelle
and justin just like yo
looking around looking nervous looking
scared i'm like bro just relax we good
right chappelle get his hair cut i go
outside the whole time i'm building
i'm scanning you know i make friends
yeah well there's a lot of women outside
as well no
yeah so you can't gravitate out there
yeah and i took a facetime call did i
not take a facetime call
calls you like what's up what's
bro we're in the uber he's just sitting
here on the phone like it's nothing i'm
like dude
wait this is weird wait just wait it is
weird
you always do that we're in the green
room chilling
yeah yeah this is crazy
this is my first time hearing this this
is strange
yeah anyways it is strange he was
terrified i was not there they were
scared
they're like oh we dressed too nice we
got nice shoes on i did say that
was like chill out the uber's like five
minutes away we can't stand here i said
it was cold out like justin is the most
worried
yes he is justin was pretty worried
jesse was scared he was like you were
hiding the wrong leg
i was i put my hand over him now he had
to be hiding it that'd be hiding it
you just took a facetime call how about
that uh nashville chicken hot
sandwiches oh dude dude oh i i text you
guys this well you saw me on the plane
oh dude so we ate me and cat well you
guys tried it too did you travel i was
about to say
the cat and chappelle tried to jj tried
it too oh and jay tried to try to trip
try to bite too the triple x hot i
smelled princess chicken
it was like a dark almost purple i kept
too much oh yeah that [ __ ] like it was
burnt
it was hot but it was like you just went
it wasn't immediately it was like an 8
for 20 minutes instead of
lingering like if you eat like a howling
race hot or you eat like
that one chip challenge it's hot right
away and but then it chills out
yeah this just wouldn't it was
consistent just
20 minutes of period and then i was like
oh this ain't a big deal i got over it
went about the shows drink it at night
and then two in the morning
princess big boy
it's time to ride and i was up
on the hour every hour from two to eight
in the morning in that toilet didn't
sleep at all
damn basically getting naps on the
toilet is what i was doing getting out's
on to it
when we got on the plane oh yeah he told
chapelle
you got to get up dog literally
he goes damn i'm on the plane funny
because like we just
we just took off we just off what had
you say man
so the seat belt sign went up yeah i got
the seat belt sign didn't even go off
yet oh no
anyway i have time for that i got
nicotine in i got
a triple expresso what did you get with
that triple x hot oh man i told you i
get up dog
and i didn't this is i looked around
like you know what i don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody thinks in here
i was in there for a while he was in
there for a hot minute you know how
sometimes you hurry because you wouldn't
be embarrassed yeah i know you need to
give
a [ __ ] i was reading articles on my
phone
you got comfortable yeah
dawg woke up i was like oh [ __ ]
it was intense i threw up between shows
because of that oh yeah did you really
but the late you'll see you guys seen
the first thick eats episode the lady
comes out and she's like y'all want it
hotter because it wasn't that hot at all
and so she comes out and she has this
like can of seasoning
and i was like yeah i want harder hotter
and she dumps it all on my
heavy hand heavy hand
she was great though yeah boltons wasn't
my favorite man
yeah a lot of people said that both and
they was like yo go to princess but
princess was alright
what yeah princess was the best it was
you know i screwed you guys because i
listened to
everybody telling me that hatty b's
ain't the spot
howdy b is better than all of them i
know it's like it's gotten real famous
you've had it
oh yeah tons of times but and then
here's the other thing again this sucks
for the episode but
uh helen ray's beats the [ __ ] off all of
them what not even close
the homeboy from la that created howland
ray's it has the best sandwich in the
world
really as far as natural chicken hot
sandwich he destroys them
it's not even close to me either well
you guys have have had hell and raised
before
which one do you guys like more out of
all the chicken sandwiches do you have
holland raised compared to prince
charlotte
was really really good yeah like but
that's why with the sandwich it was just
like
it was great in that bun
is that brioche
did you have any out there uh yeah reds
shin rose
she really didn't hang out with us i
tonight your girl i feel like had you on
a strict schedule
what did you guys do today you'd like
well we learned how to make
old-fashioned
we stopped at the country beautiful
history yeah
african american people yeah why do you
say african-american why can't you
because
mainly about yeah african-american black
people how nashville's like one of the
best places to like just say it
whatever progressive afro-american
oh what did you see uh just about a lot
of
there's a rich culture yeah but then how
they helped slave
and slavery um like a lot of those
labels you guys went on a tour on
slavery
you did a slave tour the chunk of it
yeah
just saying you did that slave choice
you said it just said
and then you learned how to make old
fashions i felt good afterwards
what a transition that's not depressing
at all it's a slave tour
they make old-fashioned you got all day
tours okay
okay ending of slavery tour that's why
how about speaking of slaves
how about he we seeing each other on the
plane he didn't say [ __ ] oh yeah this is
the thing that
alex truly believes i wouldn't say
what's up to him on a plane you didn't
notice he's on no what do you mean do
you think they all look the same
you go on that slay
damn mallet calls chin out i'm not
seeing him on the plane suddenly he goes
on a whole slave tour
this girl was like that wasn't on the
plane's schedule we have to go we have
to go chin's girl's so sweet she just
doesn't
know like how was that that's one of her
first shows she came to my show in cobbs
in san francisco
but she doesn't know like how shows work
so they come to the green room
and she's like brandon there's this
there's just this fan she seems so
sweet she says she knows you she she's
going to come to the back i was like
no she's not she's like yeah i just met
her she said she loves you and she's
coming back here
don't let her back here she goes why she
seems real nice i went
sounds crazy
and then of course we were talking that
girl outside she seemed so sweet and i'm
the one i'd be like no no no don't come
in you can't go
then i talked to manager lucy she's like
you can't let her back her she tried
getting in with theo
like she does this oh she doesn't they
pretend like they know you oh
yeah because they ordered her uber to
get home i remember that yep
she said she knew me she's so sweet
though she's like why she seems nice i'm
like they seem
they seem nice when they get back here
it gets wild oh how about
i didn't bring any dudes back to the
green room but he did
true chappelle's bringing a lot of dudes
lately
and they're all dude we did backflips in
high school together dude
i don't give a [ __ ] i like how it
switches from me
to bringing dudes at first it was like
oh it's real brings his his homegirl
you started off yeah this is two
weekends in a row two weeks in a row
we haven't been tour for two weeks two
years i'm saying two tour weekends
yeah phoenix yep you had the non-keto
friend non keto el polito none quito
you should make that which i like him i
know yeah he's cool he's out of the
house
we're nice yeah he's her friend nice had
a little
little drink in then starts throwing
jokes nonstop
so a fool full of comedians and then
turned into a two-hour podcast
nice guy though i got so many stories
about chappelle i'm like they don't care
then i was like i
everyone's laughing and i see smuggler
i'm tired
and then and they're like and then you
fake i swore this is right i'm not
making that i don't know he faked like
you were sleeping he's like
i go wake the [ __ ] up and i started
climbing your belly you're tired after
20 minutes to stand up
i was like talking [ __ ] but you didn't
see how he faced it
asleep and looked around to see if
anyone knew he was like we're standing
right now
i was thinking of jokes and i was like
sitting here and he's just like
yo hey look we're brilliant hey when
brenda gets quiet
some heat is coming out though he stared
at my flip-flops so i have these green
hairs on the plane and some busted
flip-flops they weren't buzzing
it was a new nike it was like i guess it
was like the african african
american african-american frankie
samples
dude i'm drinking fire please do this
it's red
it's yellow it's green it's orange
there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on
but it's blue on the madagascars
madagascar
he got quiet he was just staring at them
he was standing for a minute
he got quiet he hit me with that he no
no no
do you have a specific name i'm gonna
send it to you i'll take a picture i
took a picture of it
though i think they're called the
wakanda free 2.0
he killed me but how about chappelle
just like faking sleep
and brenda got quiet i didn't get it at
all
how are you gonna fall asleep with your
friend here
that's what he's he's a good guy no he's
a nice guy
yo he was bombing game one point yeah he
was a sneaker head which i enjoyed yeah
he was
not these right channels
those are dope well i'll find it but
yeah
that green room is lit the friday wait
is it not is it not those the bottom
second bottom left no those are like a
gay pride one yeah i think those are
probably i wish you showed up in those
um yes jelly roll had that room
lit bumping and then you know theo
complete opposite of me i like like
energy yeah yeah like in the green rock
music
theo i don't think he allows his
featuring mc in the same room
right he wants to be by himself quiet so
i see theo in the corner just like
steaming basically and then everybody
leaves it that's how you do it doc
yeah that's how you do it that's how i
do it man that's how i do it
we was on a roll that weekend that
friday on man that feels great
because jelly had us lit uh because he's
on this week's king the sting with
hannah baron
he had us lit even right after the
podcast he's like y'all drink tequila
i'm like not really
then his girl his fine ass girl comes
over their fine ass assistant
drops off his watch and a bunch of
tequila so we're taking shots of that
tequila
yeah he had with some michael he had the
rocks tequila
and uh theo's house then in the green
room he brought michael jordan's tequila
because all he because yeah he had to
stop drinking and his doctor's like dog
you have to stop drinking you're gonna
die and he goes that ain't an option i
got a drink
he's like if you're gonna drink with
your condition you can only drink
tequila
which i don't know tequila i don't know
i'm guessing that plant you know the
agave or something like that
maybe that's why i don't know i love
agave oh yeah that's why yeah he pretty
much just stayed on tequila that's all
you can drink he won't drink
anything else yeah michael jordan not
even a beer or anything like that nope
won't touch it you know what you know
what i've realized that he does as well
is when he does drink he'll uh he
constantly chugs water he'll drink like
nine shots of tequila
yeah he'll drink like six shots of
tequila
and then drink a whole like liter of
water right after he has a down to a
science yeah really what he does he
stays on it
he's real professional real professional
the text he was like yo
man y'all had my drunk ass drinking all
night man i got into like 5 a.m in the
morning i'm tired as hell but i'm on my
way to y'all now he's never been
overcame
i've never met him because he was gonna
be the first guest on uh
he didn't show up he couldn't show up i
could yeah he was doing right i think
he had to go get an idea oh my god
yeah i supposed to go see him in a
studio he didn't happen
he was yeah he was lit yeah you get
after now he knows how to get down yeah
he's great he's so funny he's so nice
so fun oh i met a woman who claims she
had sex with the greatest player to ever
play basketball
michael jordan what lebron james oh
wow so she goes where'd you meet her at
at the show she came to my show she
kenny you're lebron james
lebron she said yo she came out of
nowhere and i knew when a woman comes
out of nowhere she's like because i had
the lebron james goat
shirt on and she goes i [ __ ] him in
high school ooh that's aggressive
i was like hold on no no one no one
literally a white girl with that voice
yes okay
now you didn't now back in the day it
looked like she had something but right
now she came and she had like a whopper
cash she was like yo i was like listen i
will listen to this story
thing of cash yes i think i think yeah
so she bought she bought i was like yo
bob merc she was like
what do you ever you want me to buy she
i was like buy two hoodies two shirts
and get a tip xj she bought two hoodies
two shirts and gave me a tip
i was like yo if you wasn't i was i
already have a sugar mama but i mean i'm
looking for options yeah she
she goes i [ __ ] lebron in high school
he was i was 17 he was 60.
i was like well i forgive him for having
sex with you
right oh [ __ ] warlock oh my god yes i
was like yo
the rest of boys told me she had some
tigger
she had some titties on her butt some
tig but she had torah on all every one
of her i heard she took him out
what do you mean her tits is that oh
yeah yeah yeah so she goes
she took out lebron i'm like i don't
believe that
lebron didn't share a meal with this i
was about to say no this is old lebron
horny like never had a young kid
yeah big ted she showed her she was like
yo look i got these and then she goes to
take up i was like wait no
i swear she was like you want to see him
i'm like now i want to see him really
i swear you hate her what do you mean
what about the rest of the boys
it was just me it was just me and jay
james
jay was like so he was serving merch but
i see him
he goes tonight
jay's voice
[Applause]
he goes he was like hey i was like what
how about the big ass today
i said take it back we was acting like a
high school
brother's ruthless he's funny as [ __ ]
bro he's so funny we kept practicing
we were doing high school this dick the
whole weekend oh the whole weekend
was scared god asked questions yeah that
was [ __ ] funny
i love two days yo what about in that
takashi documentary when he did a
pedigree
uh he pedigreed that girl takashi
documentary you like
learn like how he got big and like he
was doing it all on purpose like
trolling and
dying his hair just be different he just
wanted the fame he loved the attention
the fame and then they show him posting
this video him uh i guess ddt
is girl yeah it was a music no it was a
pedigree pedigree it was a pedigree
triple h yeah it was like it was the
most random part of the documentary like
there was like no
i don't know there wasn't even really
context yeah it just they just showed
this part of him
pedigree and a girl and him rapping
right like it was
it was so strange she put in a music
video i never heard a pedigree when you
yeah takashi knight pedigree's hood
chick while working yeah while she was
twerking yeah
like when you watch the documentary and
one of the worst bodies in rap by the
way
yeah like she watched she was minding my
own business
i went welp i'm a fan all started
cracking the weekend we started dying
but what's weird is they show his rise
to fame and then he got in with the
trayway bloods
and they weren't really like they were
all kind of backstabbing right they like
kidnapped him they were gonna kill him
he escaped and then the whole like
trayway gang starts to get picked up by
the feds
and they pick him up and they're like yo
man you're either getting 40 years in
prison or you help us
you know work to put more people in
prison and that's when he snitched
when you watch the thing you're like i
don't blame the dude man
i know it's not popular opinion but yeah
it's not like those were his like
brothers or family
yeah like they were all backstabbing
each other and he was like it was not
doing 40 years situation
it's a bit of a shame you watch it like
[ __ ] yeah it's pretty it's pretty it's
just yes i kind of
i kind of respect him and this is what
my take away from the documentary is
like when six
nine was his final he oh he he wanted to
be famous his whole life he kept saying
like i'm gonna be famous i'll be famous
and there's one particular time when he
was on his rise he did a song with
trippy red
right and it was starting to blow up his
hate and ass friends in the beginning
put out his court document uh about him
being a pedophile
and a lot of people didn't want to touch
him a lot of hip-hop networks started
blowing them up like pedophile pedophile
and you get labeled as that you can
either quit or you can just like yo i
got to beat this and his
his over his triumph he didn't stop so
what he did was
he was okay so y'all when he doubled
down on the bloods he was like so he met
up with the the leader of treyway
and he was like yo i'm gonna be a blood
a full out blood so he bought everyone
red band
dennis and he just ditched triple red
red on gummo
and blew him up so i love when people
just like all right i'm gonna take a
negative and
i don't know the exact same that
pedophile stuff though he didn't
touch that he didn't say he was not in
the same room
he put it on social media yeah exactly
his his the
some gang members in there were hooking
up with her and he
filmed it ran a train and he posted he
posted the video
yeah but he didn't touch it but when you
when is your party of course you gotta
take for sure yeah because that's
technically child pro
pornography all right yeah yeah okay so
yeah but
just a good kid just going back gotten
caught with the right but i i
i get what you're saying about like he
didn't have to snitch and i was going to
agree with you but till he got
he had that tupac syndrome you know a
tupac moved from baltimore to l.a yeah
there's no need for it there's no need
for gang
he really believed he started calling
out hits i don't know so that's why i
was like all right if you gonna do that
then you snitch that's why a lot of
people don't respect them yeah so that's
right
it's like you jumped in jumped in the
light and as soon as it gets going bad
like you start snitching
yeah it'd be different if that wasn't
his life exactly like he didn't call
hits he didn't do all that but the fact
that they protected him when he was
trolling people
who who's the chicago rapper he's
strolling that there's chief keef
and he got shot so he chief chief
chief keef he talked [ __ ] don't put a
hit out on him
the next day chief flew into new york a
real one he's like what's up
yeah yeah real shot
no he got shot he actually got shot i
thought he got shot yeah he got
shot oh yeah but chief keef he's still
an obviously involved
with gang activity but he lives in l.a
he got out of it yeah
yeah he's from chicago real guys yeah he
lives out here yeah
he's like i don't want to be involved
with that how about how about dj vlad
just like every time you do a dj vlad
interview you telling on somebody which
i just i just saw that dj vlad cheat key
i don't know i don't think really oh you
know they missed him
oh they missed him yeah oh okay i'm
sorry so he got shot at
shout outs correct yes correct all right
thank you guys can i get some 11. that's
100 percent you know
yeah um yeah i thought it was pretty
gangster i just flew out there i was
like what are you saying
yeah but he also is smart one for
obviously things in chicago are [ __ ]
terrible he's like i'm out
and [ __ ] got out but some i think
that's
sometimes your past catch up with you in
any city like liquor king von he was in
atlanta
from chicago but what's he doing in
atlanta he was he was making music
videos he was at a clown he was at a
club yeah
you know and fighting the clothes are
open in atlanta you wouldn't think
we're popping at him my buddy frank
gorilla's filming movie out there
i know how's atlanta he goes it's like
they don't have the news
he's like there's no mass there's not
they just everything's open because i
don't restaurants every night
hotels normally like clubs club club
okay
really speaking of atlanta is that real
i'll check right now you know it's
serious
but that yeah that's where homeboy got
shot at though yeah but if you but if
you go to any city where like
for lack of veteran the goons hang out
like you know you're going to get some
issues
well yeah but if you need to get out of
it you can't
like let's say you're from south side
chicago and that gang culture
and then you fly to la and go to south
central like you're in the mid you're
you're just flying from the bad part of
chicago coming to the bad part where
they know
where those people are familiar with
your the way you move yeah
well you can't like chief keef is doing
smart he got off south side
chicago moved to calabasas or the hills
that's where he chills you didn't see
him all up in compton can you just
mention where he lived don't do that
i mean that's a big areas calabasas is
technically like a
private city too right yeah oh is it
really it
yeah most most is uh gated community
that's where drizzy is
yeah yeah everyone out there he made a
song four p.m in uh calabasas
that yeah that the song where he saw him
out uh made her right
yeah it made her right what do you think
about uh non-stop kardashian's house
because when you listen to hit the
directions he gives from his house
he's talking about pulling to kim
kardashian's house that's where they
live in the same neighborhood
yeah they're like a few blocks away from
each other it's called it's called
hidden hills
yeah so if you listen to the with the
the way he's driving in that
like maydo right when you go from his
house he's pulling up kim kardashian's
house
and that's when all the beef with um
kanye kanye
and who's the other his other boy push
it to you push your teeth started
wow rap beefs speaking of rap beat shots
like kanye
jeezy kanye and drake rap beef nobody's
getting shot over that
you know what i'm saying like that's
that's what i like
those nice boy rabbits
i mean come on
let's keep it cool guys search album
yeah
one was singing jake's a child actor i
forgot
atlanta's popping like that atlanta's
popping wow
the south is popping the south don't put
up with the same [ __ ] we got to deal
with
like you like everywhere everywhere we
go it's thinking that they're so
different like they
they laugh at us like la's so [ __ ]
ridiculous like newsom
shut down restaurants again he wants to
do a full lockdown
soon meanwhile think how preposterous
this is and i can't believe people have
put up with it
meanwhile this this [ __ ] idiot's in
hawaii
yeah his kids are in private school
still going to school
so yeah we're locking down schools
walking down this it's like but he's not
living the life
he doesn't live in regular it doesn't
affect him at all he goes i'm gonna take
a salary cut never took a salary cut
he's not affected at all by this so why
would you listen to a guy who's on top
of the mountain
trying to tell you what's like living at
the bottom of the mountain why would you
listen to that [ __ ] idiot
he's trying to listen to his rules it's
not a dick it's insane yeah
and we've seen that lockdowns don't make
a difference
bro okay they are not living they say
you you have a better chance
at getting corona or catching corona
it's like small small gatherings with
the mask
yep so the fact that we're like you want
to keep us separated it's
it's preposterous yeah borderline
malarkey
and it's funny it's fake is it is he is
he good on that word
malarkey yeah said word yeah
so everybody says you said it it worked
good
good answers i shocked a lot of people
they're like
what the hell said i think we could kill
it on family feud oh yeah
you can see the americans are putting up
with it like remember the
cdc like travel restrictions oh yeah i
saw the busiest day
ever at the airport during the pandemic
was the this past weekend people were
flying to see their families
shout out to this place then you go on
the then you go on the news and they're
like
people are traveling it's like yeah you
[ __ ] morons
they want to see their family mm-hmm
like literally this whole year been a
waste
one is like and i want to say that well
i'm just tired of the mental gymnastics
of forests like
gymnastics i don't know how to let it go
right gymnastics
saying mental gymnastics yeah of not
knowing it's because we're like in the
gray area yeah in the gray area and i'm
tired of that like
i watch cnn and i watch fox news and i
watch nbc you know why i watch any of
them i know right
all right all of them have an agenda all
of them have an agenda all of them have
one thing to do
it's all fair porn like it's all fair
media and notice like they're not saying
you don't tune in on there and they say
how great the vaccine is and
the for it's going to be dished out
that's why december 11th
yeah they don't you don't hear that do
you no you don't hear that has a 95
success rate you don't you don't hear
that they have over 300 million vaccines
that they're going to get to americans
you don't hear any of that well can you
explain because
you don't hear them saying you know him
fauci saying with this vaccine yeah
we'll be back to normal by march
do you see any of that because that's
not going to get ratings that's not what
the
news wants to do no ratings put in fair
make sure you're locked at home
make sure you don't have thanksgiving
meanwhile every one of those
[ __ ] that's telling you that
including our bitch-ass governor is
having
is having thanksgiving is in hawaii is
flying to on vacations
is going to dinners yes it's not talking
about he had to practice what he
preaches and all that when he got caught
with no man dude
you're talking about a real piece of
[ __ ] those people are the biggest
lowlifes
that we have to offer in america
politicians are the biggest piece of
[ __ ]
well well since imagine imagine that
that's your goal
especially now in politics is that's
what you want to do you got to take
funding from [ __ ] up people
you got to do shady [ __ ] you got to rub
his back so you can get this
yes it's the dirtiest of all dirt it's a
mafia
they're all mafia and they all
grandfather people that they want in
because they have this agenda
and they're going to pay them under the
table to pass this law
it's [ __ ] up dude meanwhile while he
shuts down everyone
and we can't deal with another shutdown
because restaurants can go bankrupt
he's going to shut them down for three
weeks at least
for three weeks at least i got the order
and americans aren't putting up with it
and they're not getting bailed out or
anything
nope um they don't give a [ __ ] so when
they're shutting down is it like
no outdoor seating no indoor scene just
taking it's only take out
an article he said take and then there's
a guy there's a guy today i was watching
on the news being like we
literally if if he does intact the
lockdown like we're we'll go out of
business
yeah like we can't no he's like me and
all the restaurants i see on this
will all be gone and nuisance like well
sorry trying to trying to make sure that
cover
there's no outbreak so we're gonna it's
the same [ __ ] we get
everyone gets it and it flattens
everyone gets it flat
like it's it's crazy that's so
unfortunate i wanna i wanna actually
it's such a shame it is i was reading
and they said
newsom is only doing what biden and
camilla harry says because he's
he already solidified his seat in the
white house what did that what does that
mean
i don't know well he's one of the same
so pelosi's used to be
his uh aunt she was made i forget who
someone related to him
so they're they they basically he's
gonna do what puts them in
the best light he's on their team
there's two teams red and blue
he's all blue so he's going to run the
entire
california into the [ __ ] ground he
doesn't care as long
as he can just move on and hopefully run
for you know
the the president in the future yeah how
often is there voting for
governors well he's going to lose that
every four years his
his uh approval rates in the [ __ ]
yeah he's going to lose yeah what is
that uh what do you mean
approval so people don't like them yeah
got it
people don't like him and uh also how
about cuomo wanna emmy
for the way he's handled the the the
[ __ ] corona probably up there and
emmy up there emmy for that because it's
i guess it's daytime news because he was
given updates on him
killing old people oh well i mean he had
to say it like that
that's what he did yeah headline read
different
nuts outdoor knives county restaurant
owners fear they won't survive another
cover 19 shutdown
and how crazy they just don't care sorry
dude
and they don't even bail him out i mean
like it's like hey we're gonna there's
nothing like
hey we're gonna shut you down but we're
gonna give you x amount of money to help
you during this shutdown he's running
california like a dictatorship
like he is he puts down a law and we
have to like we
will post about about like oh there's no
restaurants so who gets
even the world health organization came
out i was like man lockdowns are not you
guys aren't doing it
correctly so they said that's doing it
the way it should be yeah that's exactly
what we're supposed to do
all the only thing lockdown the only
thing lockdown is supposed to do
is to make sure hospitals don't get
overran correct make sure they're not
overcrowded correct no hospital here is
overcrowded they've never been
overcrowded not once no
not [ __ ] once my mom works at season
cy not not like oh which one
uh right there on beverly hill oh really
yeah the growth and what she did it's
not crowded right not at all yeah i have
so many friends
nurses doctors and like not nothing
never once matter of fact hospitals were
shutting down
yeah because they didn't have enough
people weren't coming in for for
alternative surgeries so they had to
shut down
wow remember man let's jump them
i wish i got my control over deebo over
nusa what'd you say when he leave
he'd be like shut up i'll be quiet leave
me leave
i'll be talking to you i keep talking
what are you guys gonna do for
thanksgiving
nothing i'm going to phoenix with uh you
have shows on
the thanksgiving night no i leave i'm
leaving friday to head out too
you're gonna drive to tempe yeah five
hour drive five and a half hours
so your shows friday tuesday friday to
friday to saturday to sunday
that'd be a good weekend but like
thursday i'll just be
at the house chilling yeah what you
doing for thanksgiving yeah it's my
son's birthday on thanksgiving oh
we'll celebrate his birthday and also
have turkey that's one downside dating
or being with mexicans they are not big
on the thanksgiving dinner
what so we we so we usually just uh
outsource the thanksgiving dinner
when back at home white people you go
all out on thanksgiving
turkey stuff stuffing y'all like
cranberry gravy that's our [ __ ]
mm-hmm now the mexicans they got
yeah they're cool not for thanksgiving
that is true i remember one christmas
she had a soup and i forget what they
call masoli
that's all they had like [ __ ] i can't
have soup for christmas
no you can't no that's not how we roll
man
not real talk by we i mean white people
that's not what we do
man what do you like on christmas ham
yeah
pepperoni pizza on uh christmas oh
christmas
yeah it was dope y'all do it different
are you upset because the two
american holidays that you have to eat
american food is overran by mexican food
it's a bummer so you eat mixture i try
to keep my son
half white we ordered i ordered i try to
keep it
hey don't forget where you came you
don't want to go full mexican
we don't eat [ __ ] soup for holidays
dude did you learn spanish dad works too
hard to freeze
super hard what does he learn in spanish
oh yeah yeah that's
tight yeah yeah damn yeah i i know i
know what you mean
i had a spanish girl uh like two like
three years ago
and then she invited me over they had
like empanadas with some frito sauce
yep that was my first time i was like yo
this is good but she was like we do that
every thanksgiving i was like where's
the turkey
where's the dress like the one like
turkey stuffing i like a nice coffee
with pecan pie pumpkin pie yeah
man peacock i've never had pecan and
then we're watching white football focal
pecan pie
oh what's that that's very difficult
no because your throat right you have
the nut thing with with your throat
oh you're allergic to nuts no i'm not
allergic you just don't like nuts
little flakes when the nuts hit the back
of your throat
yeah we're just trying to get to the
bottom of the bottle
if you're on a diet which how long i
told you on the plane how long would you
pretend we're on a diet
i've been going good go get you
here at home i'm home i'm good yeah at
home
at a caramel apple last night at like
night you did okay what is coffee what
with coffee you know what i had last
night what chilaquiles
oh i don't know what that is oh it's
like a breakfast mexican dish oh [ __ ]
yeah
i thought you know i had a big one yeah
yeah that's why i said how long
we're [ __ ] starving no one's i'm
starving my stomach's on [ __ ] fire
because prince is hot chicken
and then we had like 10 minutes before
it boarded and there's this place
have pizza's ready to go they're tiny
pan people like personal pizzas
chappelle goes you want to split one dog
i went
chappelle all right look at me how long
are we going to pretend
get your own goddamn pizza
yes you do no and then chappelle goes
man i'm hungry this is the day we're
gonna eat at
bolton's hot chicken and prince hot
chicken that morning he has chick-fil-a
hey man i think i'm gonna order
chick-fil-a
and i i just love it what i got there
was the uh grilled chicken
breakfast sandwich it don't matter i was
just about to say no you eat it oh man
then you had
i took the bread off you had jelly that
matters yeah jelly jelly who had jelly
it was like
packs of jelly i think texas i think
justin likes that jelly
texas get out of here yeah but still
oh what was that pizza we had there oh
five point pizza
so oh my god oh my god five point
pizza how about one of my favorite
pizzas i ordered it for the green room
that [ __ ] was fantastic
damn good
so good god who would have thought you'd
have found great pizza in nashville
man no who would think you'd find the
best national chicken hot sandwich in la
and the best pizza in nashville it's so
weird backwards
oh it was so good that is so nice that
[ __ ] i love when y'all order pizza
because all y'all eat pepperoni and you
have to order cheese because of me yeah
for me
and i eat the whole box to myself man
you don't need pork i ain't pork man
yeah you don't touch me the swine is
unkind and i'm a black man that's divine
yeah come on now that was a beautiful
haiku
yeah pretty shout out to this [ __ ] hell
yeah man
but no that pizza was fire i i like
nashville in general
yeah it's tight it was dope it was fun
how did y'all like it i didn't know
i loved it i can't imagine again when
we're like in the heart
heat of the lockdowns like [ __ ] knew
some i'm out of here i don't give a
prick my money anymore and so i started
looking i was looking at lake
uh travis in austin and i was looking at
two houses in
uh brentwood nashville and i was about
to pull the trigger
and i get that i just can't imagine
living there i'd like to visit but i
can't
it's so slow right it's slow right it's
great it's not
yeah i get back here i'm like get what
you paid for
yeah yeah i knew some sucks cocked but
it's like you can't be that late i have
a lot of fun
yeah it's great can't beat out although
nashville is fun yeah there's just
certain places that like
oh i like to visit this place it's nice
to visit it but
i can see that when you go there when
you're old and you have like you ready
to retire you go to nashville enjoy like
all the success of all your
you know the fruits of your money
because ellie's gonna pop up everyone's
talking
[ __ ] on it but ellie's gonna pop back
wait till this vac vaccination hits
everybody
all you [ __ ] shut up everything's
back popping the improv the store
everything uh [ __ ] you know the ice
house we can do a million spots at night
like this is still going to be the spot
to be how long are we going to pretend
that austin and nashville you know
how long are we going to pretend that
those places can be as good as l.a and
new york can that be a segment
today
no are you gonna move here like no no
like family guy when peter griffin had
his own segment you know what really
grinds my gears yeah
this is how long we're gonna pretend
we've got a job hey shout out to the
picture that came to your show
the picture yeah uh the picture picture
i'm sorry outside oh oh yeah yeah walker
beast yeah dodgers all the way came and
supported
was he pretty lit uh he came from a
wedding
oh got it because he said what's up with
me and i was like
oh this dude is lit right now i was lit
the whole time so everybody seemed
normal
jelly roll had that thing jumping cool
dude though yeah yeah
beast man yeah shout out to him hey the
pot you said uh
will compton and his boys showed up yeah
they came they came here yeah they came
jay saw him i didn't see him afterwards
oh hannah baron came
hannah came with a man yeah you know
what was weird i was trying to play it
cool
but i love moose like after the scene uh
montana i love moose
i love mooses yeah and i was talking
about hunting he's like you ever shot a
moose i was like
and he's like oh man ain't nothing like
shooting a moose he's like check this
video out oh i was trying to be like all
outdoors i'm like damn let's see where
this at like talking about like honestly
it's not gonna last
i'm like damn what's the draw there
trying to you know whatever yeah and
then he
brings this video of him like from you
to me of this
beautiful moose probably oh dude
16 foot tall giant horns the moose is
just
chilling on a saturday like he's in the
plants like this
and he rolls up mooses like what the
[ __ ] pops up
he draws back this big-ass air i'm like
oh please don't kill that beautiful
animal
shack right in the [ __ ] side i'm like
oh
he was looking to sit i'm like yeah no
doubt dude then that's just he takes off
running and then you see him
fall and you see his hoofs go in the air
yeah and there's a picture of him next
to the [ __ ]
moose like this and the giant antlers
are like damn you got him dying
so you would never go hunting no no not
for a moose i can't kill them
i i like uh i like watching those videos
like i don't like this
interesting people thank you
that made me sad yeah listen to all the
animals thank you
like you kill a dare
they're not they're different than the
other animals like they're cool you know
they're [ __ ] dinosaurs they're so big
like how can you miss also i'd be so
scared
they're aggressive you know you know the
lights they like to fight hell yeah
there's
if there's like little cats around it
will [ __ ] you up well little okay
find a video of a moose [ __ ]
something oh dude uh moose
[ __ ] up person do that what oh wait it
attacks a pickup truck that's better
okay no one gets hurt right no i like
seeing people get [ __ ] up because i
have to watch a video look at that thing
so that moose is ain't [ __ ] compared to
the one i saw that's nothing why are you
following him
see how i don't know why you fought when
this that's not even a big boy
yeah let me see a moose [ __ ] up but
dude a moose attacks man
yeah we can wait a little while right
now okay
god look at the top one
but even this like the moose he showed
was dude it was not what
16 foot tall from hoof to horn woke up
at his home almost with ivy and its
horns and stuff i thought it was kind of
cute but
i thought it was kind of cute anything
but q
[Music]
oh oh that's terrifying
scared the crap
dude that's trying to like uh kill it
you don't see that one you know the life
rate of a deer
i don't i found out the life rate of an
octopus this weekend oh you saw shout
out to jacob's job
yeah three years three to five three to
five what's happening here
that moose is just waiting for that dude
nothing
nah moose are cool man go to where the
deer beats deer beats up man
dear beats up man yeah watch it's crazy
this show is crazy
there's a deer beats up man i want but i
can see a deer oh this one has an old
school one
oh yeah let me see something you ever
seen that one shout out to bambi
oh hands yeah hand stand up strike oh
hell yeah beating the piss out of his
ass you ain't killing me today
how heavy is his hooves i don't know
that's those things like
three four hundred pounds probably
doesn't feel oh that's a big one too
look at this dumbass
he not he relentless yeah damn
and he's just not stopping yeah god dude
show a little problem
look he got look he got look no this
guy's a giant [ __ ] though
he look at that that top one got him
brendan what would you do with that deer
was attacking you not that
what would you do i don't know you'll
take him down exactly he doesn't know
what to do here i would i wouldn't curl
up and get my ass what that is
that is true you don't want me to know
i'm gonna get i'm gonna [ __ ] grab his
eye that's what i'm gonna do
his eye yeah i'm gonna grab his face he
liked mooses
if it's attacking you gotta defend
yourself man i'm going for the [ __ ]
eyes
kangaroo enjoy your victory with one
[ __ ] eye there
might [ __ ] me up but i bet you will see
how yeah you ain't gonna you're gonna
see all the way
you ain't doing that too you're gonna
die they're so big yeah
lisa yeah i'm glad that i didn't kill
him but kangaroos got like who got the
best like
fighting hands as an animal kangaroos
you ever seen kangaroos fight
yeah they're like box boxes kangaroos
tail and they stay they stand on their
tail and
kick how do you kill a kangaroo oh with
a gun huh
yeah they eat kangaroo over in australia
right like as a normal meat
well they eat it for sure about that
they eat it yeah yeah
homeboy was saying though like he had
like i forget how much
uh like 600 pounds of meat or 700 pounds
of meat oh yeah from moose from that at
his house
no so he said it's expensive to ship so
some of the guys he was with took meat
and then he had like 100 pounds shipped
to him
he says moose some of the best meat
would you eat moose
yeah i just don't want to kill it
they're cool looking man
you don't want to kill it yeah but
you're eating i don't like it but you
eat it yeah
i would try it it's already dead you
know
moose i don't eat it
no you've had octopus right calamari
yeah
and i've never had grilled octopus
tentacle also i like octopus as well
that's huge that's really good
apparently they're very intelligent
octopus but you know me and jay like to
live three to five years
yeah really you know all of them die is
it like you die out or
just like hunting they don't no they die
out oh like naturally three to five
years i had no idea oh that's a short
while because what was it something with
their organs
something happens and they basically
starved it it's a horrible yeah they
starve
something happens to their bodies where
their intestines they can't eat anymore
and they just basically starve to death
have you watched the documentary on
octopus on netflix no it's
such a great documentary it gives you
something jay was telling us about it
why are you talking like that
yeah right like a philosopher yeah have
you seen
it was a long weekend i thought you were
gonna ask me about asian people eating
it raw
wait y'all i think in japan or korea
yeah it's like a certain place and they
shove it in no yeah no they don't
the tentacles the the locks was like god
no and then they just
shove it apparently there are two coins
i've been wanting to have live octopus
for a long time what's wrong with you
why would you do that i mean it's just
the tentacles moving so it's just nerves
oh but it's ways to eat there's one
there's a little one from the bottle
you have to chew it and then you've
never seen the tentacles i think we
talked about this on cats have you ever
seen the
they i forget what ethnic ethnicity
asian
where they they suck off them clams and
them oh yes
i know what you're talking about you
boil it super sexy it is
a bunch of asian girls eating let me see
oh i think they're talking about it it's
super sexy i mean
you want to watch the octopus ones let
me see the octopus let me see these
things i was first
suck off these clams oh is it [ __ ]
wait it's a challenge octopus challenge
no look this is this is a lie that's a
full body
that's their head see there's she's
eating one of two
ways there's one that's live where you
chew it up and try to kill it and then
swallow it
and then the other one is you will uh
take away the
tentacles chop it up and because the
nerves are still
kind of uh intact it like moves around
even though it's technically she dipping
it in soy sauce soy sauce
that's disgusting all right i'm good
25 million views what is that pink stuff
that's ginger like sushi ginger oh i
love ginger that's what this one's not
moving around
now that's disgusting that's nasty my
stomach is turning right now
there's something that's like wow here
we go wait what is this watch homegirl
here
this is the one yeah she takes it to the
head literally she takes it to the dome
no pun intended okay
oh i mean out here eating ursula
[Music]
what what uh kind of asian is she i
can't tell
grab it by the neck she looks mexican
she kind of looks mixed
okay so this is the full octopus yeah
this is like the octopus is still alive
that's why it's like
it's quick
[Music]
this seems like korean bbq because
i will say she's taking it like a champ
oh i feel sick yo all right all right
good uh
oh no no it's not here
he's trying to fight back he's trying to
fight back brendan look white look away
all right
i got to make sure she swallows it so
it's legitimate
i know right oh my oh no
he's disgusting yeah oh that guy's like
why am i on this date
yo is that he on the date this is all
for you like she's taking a shot this is
our first date
right oh like you now she wiped them out
oh my god that was horrible that was
that wait how many of you should you
don't know these girls sucking
ducks though my stomach hurt yeah it
made me feel
[ __ ] sick how do you spell guinea eo
and then
have anyone had a ghee duck uh i've had
guidok where like they
chop it up in little slivers it's
attractive though
it looks almost like a scallop when you
eat it properly some girls will eat it
like this
on purpose because it looks you know
it's in it
yeah i thought some [ __ ] you know how
like if she come at you guys about to
hit you
yeah super sexual wait what is this yeah
snap that [ __ ] girl
handle it handle it girl keep peeing
he's filled with juice so wait wait dude
i want to see him suck it that she just
bit it
yeah that's what they bite that
[ __ ] no but y'all say suck on
them they suck it now
i want some suck it though all right
just you know we can't really have any
of this on air we got in trouble last
time from jesus
we're doing this yeah oh
oh but yeah these videos apparently get
like millions and millions of views we
should get some on here
what bro we don't need to do that i you
want to say sometimes we gotta draw walk
the line yes
we already we already get the hot
chicken and [ __ ] bro we don't need to do
you want to see him do it
episode two of thick eats gooey duck
he went far oh they do it it's guys i
don't see a guy
wait wait go to the dudes hit that this
one yeah
see dangling ding-a-ling
[Laughter]
is that c dangling oh but they're not
like taking it's just
yeah it's oh they're not alive oh that's
why i don't got a hundred thousand views
you had a second huh you gotta eat the
sea dingling no
you gotta suck this thing man yes okay
pulse all right we're good
we're good god bonnie
what's the next food challenge not that
i mean
i like that poor octopus that may feel
so sick so chin you want to eat
you want to do that not we're not the
whole octopus i
i also care about the animals too so i
don't want them to suffer but i would
kill it first and then eat the live
tentacle or the moving tentacles
because it's fresh it's like i think
there's a few places in k-town where you
can do that right
there's one i think prince or something
disgusting what does it taste like
you guys don't like sushi no i i just
stay away from
i don't like it octopus but it's still
seafood that's
fresh do you like sushi i like sushi i
don't like like
like i don't like like eel and all that
[ __ ] oh really
the only one that's cooked bro hold on
just stop talking about it yeah i got my
stomach
yeah yo you need to throw up everyone
one [ __ ] night when he
when she that thing tried to that was
that was too much oh my
god she over there just like she has to
look mexican she
said she was from america that's what i
said in the description yeah she's an
american
a lot of pennies on us no that's not us
it's not unless we don't claim her yeah
hell all right what do you got for
current events all right
let's take a break from the shenanigans
because i want to tell you about
this electric stand-up scooter that came
into my
life like a wrecking ball
it's called unagi it's incredible it's
total electric
super portable it can transform super
easy it only weighs
26 pounds 15 miles of range all right
it's super easy um you can cruise around
and they got a crazy black friday deal
for you guys it's made of carbon fiber
listen you can break it down easy handle
and you can bring into restaurants
whatever you want to do with it
don't jump on those other rental things
where you have an app on your phone
where it has diseases on it or it's low
on battery it's always a nightmare
getting all that stuff
nope take ownership of the way you
cruise around
no more subways no more uh freaking
ubers
you got this dope ass scooter and i'm
talking about unagi scooters
if you order with the web address i'm
about to give you a full for black
friday
it's 200 off the best electric scooter
on the planet
so go to unagiscooters.com fighter
again that's u-n-a-g-i scooters dot com
slash fighter
they're only going to do 500 of these
with this black friday deal
so get your mind right get yourself the
best luck scooter and ride free
uh it's unagi scooters dot com slash
fighter
it's about to be a first one okay so a
man in florida was walking his dog he
has this tiny little it looks like a
chihuahua
a juvenile alligator came up and grabbed
it because the dog wasn't on a leash
this man jumped into the swamp and
wrestled the alligator until
its jaws opened and released the dog my
girl sent me this last night let me see
that's very sad oh it's a little one
yeah it's
little ones means there's big ones
oh yeah he's gonna snap it he's gonna
snap the alligator
what's he doing with it no just kidding
no he's just no he's holding it the end
doesn't really show him like getting out
the man did an interview and said that
his dog was fine he only had
a like a small puncture on his leg but
his hands are like all chewed up now
well look how he came out chalk that up
as a loss my dog gets bit by now
i love you but look how he came out the
water like undertaking coming out the
casket like this
he had some pipes
for the beginning the alligator's like
what the [ __ ]
he came out
right that dude's gangster man because
because there's other alligators in that
water yes no they ain't just wanted
this is in florida this is in florida
yeah yeah they all look like you must
really love that dog
oh you're gonna go back wow i guarantee
he tell that story well listen i had my
first wife jesus christ
gave me the puppy she passed away so i
figured yeah
it's a southern john wick is that what
you're saying southern his name richard
will banks
well my name is richard will banks
a dog gunner went down there in the lake
and he told him to stay down
okay all right well all right okay
do you guys remember drake bell of
course he was on the nickelodeon show
drake and josh
oh okay well he's an uh nickelodeon
actor he was really big
as a like what what
who no no no i've never heard him
he's a big like teen actor in the early
2000s he tried to transition out into
a music career oh he's all thick
no he is the skinny one josh peck was
the
thick one yeah but he recently uh
went on to social media and changed all
of his social media handles
to the name drake company companion
and he is now doing spanish music he
moved to mexico
and he's doing like this whole rebrand
he only types on social media in spanish
he does only spanish music and he's kind
of like claiming mexico now
i love it wow find yourself can you do
that you got to do something i mean
it says he might be rebranding because
that accused of sexual
what uh so last year his ex-girlfriend
from like 10 years ago came out on tick
tock and said that
he abused her when they were in a
relationship he came out and said
it wasn't true and that she asked him
for money apparently it's like verbally
and physically abusive
they don't really go into too much some
fans speculate that belle's rebrand
could be tied as denial of
abuse allegations made by his
ex-girlfriend august
fairly recent but yeah but apparently
the abuse happened 10 years ago like
they haven't dated
any time recently and she wants money
you said yeah he came out and
when the accusations were posted onto
tick tock he said that
she actually hit him up like a month
before asking for financial help and he
helped her and now
that happened it's kind of like a big he
said she said
but yeah drake bell is mexican now
apparently do we have any of his mexican
music yeah on his
instagram i don't know i think you can
find it on youtube drake campana
yeah i wanna see his instagram i bet
it's a [ __ ] show yeah
shout out to drake and josh cause that
birthed i carly that was your that was
your
[ __ ] that was the spin-off that was
expensive because miranda uh
about real mexican by the way miranda
she that's 4.5 million
followers four point five one four yeah
put that
oh damn sorry people [ __ ] with it go to
that middle one chin
yeah he's about to sing right there okay
let's hear it oh damn look all spanish
where is this in mexico that is a white
boy
yeah is this just him walking around
this abandoned oh my god that's so cool
there's no way just post this [ __ ]
it's almost a minute right
yeah it might be like the intro to his
music video
yeah it's all sad hello hello it is
in spanish wow
oh here he goes he's not playing the
guitar in them oh there you go yeah it'd
be funny of all his
what is he talking about right here in
the top left apologizing for that hey
drake bell here just letting you know
i'm available on cameo for any type of
special messages
he went right he went back to caucasian
how long we and pretend
that when somebody jumps on cameo
they're doing good in life
how long are we gonna pretend
if you're on camera you ain't doing it
because you got a lot of options
they came at your boy i said get the
[ __ ] out of here
they came they came at you all the time
still all the time
yo hey couple of your friends are on
here i don't give anything
hey come on be your friends huh just
talk about it
ryan was on there for two dollars
singing happy birthday every [ __ ]
sunday
stop it you're coming to the studio
doing cameos oh you would
yeah it's funny you see us in the back
he's like you sing a happy birthday to
fame
yeah brian yeah someone's like hey can
you sing happy birthday that you know
i'm like happy birthday dave you know
like
what would you do what would you do
nothing i want nothing i don't want any
part of it
i talk too much for a living i don't
need another outlet
a [ __ ] dog i get i got a
cleaner you don't have a clean he's been
saying that forever hey
burn those
i just want to hear this dumbass sing
yeah
seriously see he wasn't even speaking
spanish on his when he was promoting i
don't know
this dude how spanish is this is a white
dude trying to figure you know
i don't think he's spanish or mexican
you know lost you got to be to
switch your whole vibe up and start
singing spanish what if his music is
dope though
is let's better worse than vince paul
let's pause it better
better than vin diesel let's go around
the room go oh wait real quick this
could be the other reason why he's
doing this shenanigans you know lap
music was the most streamed genre of
music
out of any other music genre in the
world lap music
really so like balvin bad bunny
uh my favorite uh well i love
uh maluma and then uh carol carol g do
you know what carol g yeah carol and
she's
right mm-hmm yes okay yeah i know um
yeah carol g is like she's khloe
kardashian if she had talent
she looks identical
she's such a baddie recently single
broke up with the
whole boy yeah who's awesome what his
name is yeah but he's the guy who did
the song with uh takashi six nine
they're best friends he's argentinian
that's your favorite song you said by uh
six nine of him yeah dude the women in
that video
i didn't even see it yeah they she bro
yeah that's the girl right yeah that's
him
i love carol annual anew annual
you said she's single now yep they broke
up she's bad she watches
oh she's so bad i don't know she just
shot sure
she does look like chloe yeah she said
she's chloe if chloe had talent
continuing
okay let's see dumb ass real quick
right hello give a tech is better than
vin diesel um
i doubt it's better than me who else had
a song vin diesel who else had a song
that we were listening to
i think it was just vin diesel was it
just him but he had like christ chet
hanks
oh oh yeah do i also celebrate go check
it out all right so no more anything
okay i bet vin diesel is just
it's way more produced so it sounds
better probably but this guy's
who knows what this guy is maybe he's
writing his own [ __ ] okay he might be
would you say
this [ __ ] probably trash oh yeah i'm
with you all right
[Music]
so we're speaking english
there's like a little part in spanish
there so mostly
english but not a great singer right
chin yeah i mean i can't tell
it's it's like it's hard it's hard
that's awesome
right there chimera's playing the
[ __ ] guitar
you pissed off so hard on this guy right
now
i mean he's playing but there's also a
track playing
okay so he's not bad at all okay he's
not bad he's actually a pretty good
guitar
oh carefully drop that n word buddy
he's not terrible he has to be spanish
right he can't just be a white boy he's
like you know what
let me try getting on this latin craze
right now yeah
some background shout out to the spanish
people maybe
about it says his ethnic background is
mostly white
he has not been vocal about having
latino heritage at all
oh that's hilarious where was he born a
newsport
english scottish and swedish a white boy
from newport
all right well dude i love that someone
on google was like we don't claim him
basically someone said that caucasian it
just says caucasian
caucasian white as [ __ ] nice nice try
drake
he's nice with the spanish but no he's
white yeah he's doing that that's why
he do what you do bro for him good for
him it's a it's a field
for everyone yeah find your own mind
your way yeah
he has english scottish and swedish
ancestry he's white
white white white swedish is white white
as white as it gets oh man thank you
thank you champions shout out though
she's my favorite
i don't know all the letters my girl
knows this oh okay she's my hall pass
one and that's that that's the one i
thought it'd be halsey
yeah you said you said that pat in the
past yeah maybe
stop depressing i know yeah what else
you got jen this right here
this one's for uh chappelle i forgot who
tagged us
in it but this little girl skateboards
and she's adorable
three years old okay
oh damn it this is insane anyone with
kids knows for
three year old be doing this is no oh
it's insane especially she's a little
badass
oh that's a quarter yeah mm-hmm well she
wants to
cut it she's gonna cut it you should
probably cut it
some dude put here's the comments weak
as [ __ ]
i'm way better at skating yeah 325 like
[ __ ] trash yo she crashed at the end
what the [ __ ]
dang she's a little beast yeah for three
years old like that's
nuts with a tutu oh oh damn she stays on
it she's doing an ollie
four years old wow nuts for a
four-year-old
look at her go i want to show you how it
is too damn
good on her man she's gonna be a killer
skateboarder yes
cool that's awesome british
she's so cute so cute she stays in a
little tutu
yeah so beautiful
almost cute man yeah
oh that was heartwarming okay
so last week a video of a woman quitting
walmart
went viral because she quit on the
intercom calling everybody out
saying you're cool [ __ ] you i'm out
basically she's a bad
bad skin yep she uh
well okay you're not wrong
but everyone struggles that's the thing
about it
i'm looking at her skin i'm like maybe
she needs to exfoliate you know what
mask
acne is real i'ma give it so badly
without proactive
neutrogena will help you right go ahead
okay but uh yeah
we have a video for equipment yeah she
recorded it and she posted it on to
tiktok hell yeah
did she quit it was cvs you said uh
walmart
this one yeah finally quit hold on
finally quit my top finally quit my
toxic job that was making me absolutely
miserable for a year and seven months
[ __ ] walmart i like walmart kevin hurt
got a good job
i just want to say that y'all tray way
[ __ ] walmart
attention all walmart shoppers
associates
and managers my name is shawna from cap2
and i just want to come on here and say
henry is a racist sticky
prick johanna is racist elias is a prick
of a manager
this company fires black associates for
no reason this company treats their
employees like [ __ ]
especially cat 2 and she's so nervous
jimmy from sporting goods
joseph the cashier larry from garden
center
to read it and i hope you don't talk to
your daughters
the way you talk to me
shout out to ariel [ __ ] love you
[ __ ] the managers [ __ ] this company [ __ ]
this position and [ __ ] that big lazy
[ __ ] chris price i
[ __ ] quit shout out to chris price
i'm out i think there's no one there
well imagine you was in there like
shopping no one cared though yeah
oh god yes
i love how i love how no one did
anything right yeah very cool yeah
oh okay good day yeah very big
corporation
yeah we're enormous see ya oh yeah this
is the one i wanna see this yeah this so
this girl let me set it up for him chen
this girl is a seven-year-old boxer and
i love this and she got hands right
so her dream her favorite fight is earl
spence so steve harvey
like presented she was interviewing she
was like who's your favorite boxer
earl spence boom he was in training camp
boom
let me hit it with this go ahead i got i
got somebody i want you to say hello to
okay uh i want you to say hi to the
unified walkway
look at her reaction
look at her man you never know what you
do how it affects somebody
that's why man it like kills me when i
hear
dudes talk about well i'm not a role
model i ain't here for your children
you don't know who you're here for you
have no idea man
that some young kid somewhere is looking
at you
from a distance just just wanting to
turn take him serious with that mustache
isn't it
he does kind of look like mr potato yeah
i'm used to it now he's so aggressive
she cries go to her go to her
look at her [ __ ]
she nasty shout out to her man oh my god
she nasty with it look it's another one
it's another one
so cute whoa
and the one on the end is the one she
kills it look at this one
jesus christ come on man
wow shout out yeah shout out to you
so cute earl spence man go ahead he won
the fight just off
pure that pure nobody's [ __ ] with her
at school
no he don't fight this weekend december
5th yeah next weekend
we'll be in boise not this weekend but
the fun weekend yeah
but you guys uh danny garcia oh yeah
danny garcia is no pushover but i think
that no spend some bad
pajama i think spence listen i don't
want him as an uber driver but he's a
bad
pajama okay i talked to him hardcores
will get that
he was in a lamborghini
because it shot him out of the car
because he wasn't wearing a seat belt
yeah they said he would have been
running a seat belt he could have died
look here's a picture of him after the
car crash can you click on his uh
profile
he was just drunk now he was joking
leaving a party he just beat sean porter
he was drunk
oh he just got done with the fight yeah
no no no no no no
like weeks or months after the [ __ ] he
was definitely drinking go down
go down it's right he posted a picture
he posted a picture he's like
his car was completely
a little bit and they said that's what
saved him he's right and
he walked off and was fine go upstairs
he recently just posted oh right there
so go to that picture where the car
crash
the car crash up top top chin right
there yeah that one and click over
look at this one boom what do you mean
he just had a bunch of bruises
she he was dude from getting tossed from
a car in the ferrari going like he was
speeding as well
how fast he was going i talked to his uh
his homie he was like bro
we thought he wasn't going to make it
and uh now he's a
handsome dude too set a set of chompers
on him
yeah look at him now look look at the
shape he's in now cut his hair
uh go up his recent pitch right there
that second one chin boom
my man in shape baby my man in shape
baby
you put everything i bet anything on
that man right there we got this brendan
yeah i think he'll beat the [ __ ] out of
uh
danny garcia with them body shots danny
garcia go see what's happening
but yeah yeah i believe i see i think i
see it too small for him too small yeah
now y'all can look like that if y'all
stayed on that diet i don't think so
okay
what else you got some more i'm still
working my ass off just to let people
know
so yeah me too
we
you think that's what got you guys here
here's my step i mean
chappelle about it we don't eat that
much on the road we'll have like it's
really a deal
and then like when we landed i had
chipotle that's all i ate to the next
date at two o'clock
so as far as calories in color's out i'm
not eating a ton at all
what's up malik malik talking [ __ ]
like you guys eat very calorically dense
when you do but it's not a lot it's like
just
a couple pieces of tenders and then now
that's a good way to store
fat but it's one so do we need more
salads is that a thing we shouldn't
quit eating dude we gotta stop
fiber might help the only way to lose
weight ostrich should be 300 pounds
the only way to lose weight is you got
to stop [ __ ] eating so much
yeah bottom line and your body adjusts
you got your trap all i had was eggs and
bacon this morning
too much too much eggs and bacon too
much because he's like
calories yeah in this piece of bacon if
you only do that
if you only eat proteins and fats then
it's cool but if you start adding stuff
when you came here i saw you chomp down
a bag of cheetos then yeah then you kill
it
this week she's like for boston's
birthday i was like yeah you are right
and then she goes oh uh my friend's
sister made sure she has like a
service where she does like uh halloween
like candy
and like birthday stuff she makes like
dope like cake pops like
oh the same person who did the halloween
party right oh my gosh
that's her best friend's sister so she
makes all these guys this [ __ ] was so
good
last night did you make something we
were watching married at first sight we
got a fight before
we were watching me at first sight
before awkward because we were fighting
before that
i want to know what the fight is about
dude so then
i said i said cut up that cut up that
apple now so
i put on a nice decaf dark roast i ate
and uh she goes i go we'll just split it
she's like splendid
so then she cut up her own which was
it's peanut crushed caramel apple and
mine was an oreo caramel apple
so it's the oreo oh my god i'm big on
texture it's just the texture of all the
little crust of oreos in your mouth it's
just marin and then that then that then
that caramel hits the back you don't
know
but how about i roll up to this house
this [ __ ] was like hey yo pull
it
uh just come to the back shoes i can't i
said i'll be in the hot tub
in the back music blasted
shoulders
[Applause]
in the hotel how about in the airbnb
this weekend i heard you guys talking
[ __ ] i came running upstairs button
oh bruh i said who talking [ __ ] hold on
bro he ran up gateway
gary wearing
i was scared to come out the room
that's all i need i was like what's
going on you sent you the picture
i had to send it to you watch it look at
him dude because when you get in the tub
we mean my son's getting in with our
undies we ain't trying to get
swimsuits and all that we're just
getting our undies right in the hot tub
different types of music
you sound like that black golf american
dad when he was like selling them hot
tubs
it's not for you pull to the back of the
castle man come
goes damn this crib's nice and went a
lot of dick jokes
you could also just air drop to my
computer okay here we go yeah
yeah you're not an air drop hold on i'll
do it again man see how i don't know why
everybody want an air drop just
text it to me i'm texting him but it's a
long video just text
it's just a picture though it's not
coming up there we are i i got you you
got it now yeah i got it okay cool
you uh you said you're a girl and doing
anything for thanksgiving
no she works that day come on over don
can i mm-hmm
i'll come over yeah i don't know when i
i'll tell you
with
i don't like getting my hair wet wait
what
i think you need a shower oh yeah yeah
he had the music blasted
yeah hell yeah this tiger was over there
yeah this tiger's just
cruising around you needed his goggles
yeah he's like i need to get goggles
like chappelle grab them goggles
yeah he's just gonna yeah grab the shoes
out of the mailbox
it's a party dude it is a party oh gosh
what else you guys got um you guys were
talking about khloe kardashian
oh and this is her newest look right now
so she accepted an award why people hate
on her they hate hers
i mean i don't get it does she not look
[ __ ] great hold on now will she not
look better
is that her that's her but she looks
sharp to me just very short chin looks
sharp yeah
you know what she looks like fine you
can be nervous who gives a [ __ ]
i don't get it oh she changed her face
okay she's hurt
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] i like the
whole face yeah i like all of it her
bodied up everything i like her body
though it looks like she's skinny in
that like video though
this is so awkward but i'm only doing
this because you are one person awkward
but i am like i honestly
and truthfully no [ __ ] i
cannot believe that like you guys did
this
you guys picked me to win a people's
choice award and that
i think is more to me than i'm not
feeling it any more brendan
no i'm still okay that's good
she sucks the meanest dick this side of
the hidden hills
i hate when they have hidden hills
do you think she does better than kim
ooh i've seen kim's work
she's wet kim wack well i think she's
got a lot better
how you know what it's been that's a
long time okay
well something all right she got reps
all right she got a reps i hate when
they have like the long red claws like i
don't like that
when their nails are yeah like when it's
like way long like
i'm not mad at it oh okay what you don't
like like really like
strong like look how long cats are no
hers is way
longer than look some girls will go
really long she
look look so how would she look without
makeup
look how long you see i'm saying like
that's like a red hot chili chocolate
chili pepper still into it okay all
right but that was not nails those are
claws you know that right like i'm sure
i'm still into it
scratch your back you say she would like
she would look pretty normal without
makeup yeah
um i think so that's the i feel like she
has
enough money to take care of herself
what the [ __ ] did you you know how big
she used to be
need to get on her diet chappelle true
well let's reach out to her
yeah chloe i think she might get
something i think she used to have
like a fitness app i don't know how
accurate that was she's just like some
nerve wrans
come on skip you better talk that talk
yes
i was i was waiting for someone to say
look how big she was
compared to now i had to do she was busy
she looks great she was like one of
justin's girl
she was you can't do my man like that
but yes that's true you know what i'm
talking about
do the side by side there chin you see
her they have it for you down there
she's in black
and oh yeah right there right there come
on now
like people are like yo she's changed
yeah for the better
upgraded good for her yeah that's right
yeah
should be a [ __ ] grand cherokee she's
a [ __ ] ferrari now look at her
wait she's skinny now yeah yeah see i
don't like that you got blood ass now
though
she got a lot of what blow out ass
oh she got it yeah brazilian butt lift
fat oh
what is a brazilian butt lift it it's
where they're your stomach
oh it's like a tummy tuck and it's
pretty cool how about you know uh
[ __ ] damn
that's a brazilian butt lift boom sign
me the [ __ ] up
you know um uh
you know uh kanye got uh lipo oh yeah
cause you ever heard him go off he goes
man y'all made me so self-conscious from
my wedding i [ __ ] got lipo yeah
[ __ ] i'm about to do you making me some
comments about my weight that is true
yeah i know there's a mexican doctor
that's a specialist
he'll take pre and post photos and pre
dudes are just like
fat and then he literally sketches in
six packs
sucks out all the fat yeah looks dumb
i'd rather just work on it it'd be
embarrassing can you imagine yeah yeah i
know right
yeah yeah been i've been gone for two
weeks i've come back shredded
be weird hey
be awkward like brent is there something
you want to tell us no how do i
i'd rather just work on it yeah but
here's the thing it's not working is it
for us
we just got to stop eating yeah you know
what yeah i gotta separate myself from
you you do have to say
no we're doing it it is the team
together let's see what he does
i tried to split the pizza he said how
long are we gonna pretend like
i'm like i'm realistic with it we
haven't eaten all
day our stomach's hurt we got one time
to eat you went hard on me because i had
eggs and a couple of pieces of bacon you
just did that well i said if you want to
lose weight we gotta stop eating
i gotta stop eating that no no you guys
well but here's the problem you washed
it down with cheetos
you know you [ __ ] up right
you know you [ __ ] up right
so you said you had to exactly 852 you
had eggs and bacon
knife
[Laughter]
those cheetos aren't even a lot of
calories
i'm okay wait wait wait wait wait wait
what's yours what's yours
oh i say 90. what's yours 140 140 what's
yours 120. i got one 110.
160. oh so did i say
i said 140. 15 15 grams of carbs
that's the problem the carbs the carbs
10 grams of fat maybe i need to listen
to chin
uh-huh just dude chin's not the most
weight of any don't look
i'm thick i don't know if you ask me
weight loss
i'm struggling with myself chloe what
did you do i struggle with you i'm
asking chloe
talk to chin chin you speak 300 pounds
and chin is good about it because he
lost the weight and he kept it off a lot
of people will lose a lot of weight and
then gain it back in chin doesn't work
out yeah i don't
between i probably averaged 27 miles
every day
you do you want it and i'm still
fighting i think i think you know i'm
going to start running canyon
uh runyon canyon everything yeah you're
going to start running running yeah
it's a long it's a long way today that'd
be fun is running closed down
because uh you know they're not closing
parks yet okay
but i mean yeah they closed parks i'm
gonna post a video every day at a park
hey uh before me while we're on bikes uh
i watched kevin hart
uh special he was talking about he was
doing bike riding and he said that like
he had
access to yeah he got really into biking
yeah he got really into road biking
kevin hart did a ton of road biking a
lot of guys do you know who's a big
biker but
he doesn't really talk about it he's
really big because we have the same
liaison that's specialized is jason uh
mamoa i love him huge biker really big
time the specialized bikes
called road he's like i have he has talk
about aquaman
yeah yes the diamonds absolutely drago
is what the real fans would call them
drop yes
oh cause of game of thrones did you just
say grain
from from gang of thrones okay
survey says
all right well [ __ ] i'm one for three
he's a big biker
i love him motorcycle but he's like like
thick boy bike club
who doesn't love him i see him in uh off
to pango he lives off topic i see him
all the time down here he
him he's dude wife breathtaking in
person
yes jason momoa is breathtaking you're
like oh there's an a-lister i look like
[ __ ] [ __ ] damn
are you does he have a wife and stuff
yeah you know uh monet
monet dog from cosby show bro
oh with the dress lisa bonnie
what did you say i said monet service
he's got kids too so
he's he's such a big biker uh they sent
him bikes because he's shooting in
hawaii i think
they sent him he wanted the new but they
have a new bike out and they're
completely sold out and he's like i'll
pay for whatever
just send it to this location hawaii
because he just he bikes like i do every
day oh but
his is working now he's jack he's
not you you think you're a good looking
dude and then you get next to jason mama
look at those eyes
i'm across the 300 he's a phantom yeah
yeah i love that reference by the way
look at go to lisa bonnet that's his
wife right there and she's i know
but she was used to being married to
lenny kravitz yeah right yep they have a
kid again i have a kid zory kravitz
i tried to just have it she's all right
to me he's really i think she definitely
out kicked her coverage with him
well she's he that boy is fine she's
beautiful she's what happened today
i think he talked about
i think it's one of those things where
uh he grew up and she was his celebrity
crush
yeah yeah he said he was real nervous to
talk to her the first time
look at this how long have you been
married a while
she's so hot you know what i take
backwards she was beautiful yeah yeah i
was about to say you trained them older
women i'm trying to tell you that's what
it
is
he uh you know when he was when he was
shooting game of thrones when he was
drago like the drago he was dead broke
lemonade fan with his best friend
he was like wish he was like he was
weird because game of thrones was such a
big hit
and i was starving like he goes i would
like be on the beach like looking for
food and people like [ __ ] drago this
is nuts what are you doing here was that
his first like big yeah and he like i'm
[ __ ]
that's my van he started acting when he
was younger like 20
early 20s he was on baywatch originally
he said that baywatch
[ __ ] him because after he got on the
show like nobody would touch
his agents like dropped him you to get a
job for you because no one took it
seriously yeah no one took it seriously
it's like a joke
yeah what do you do on baywatch today
like he was just on his pigeonhole
it's like you know people like oh he's
that guy from baywatch so he couldn't
get another gig
yeah drago he was super young and skinny
too
yeah well he had to change his look of
course yeah
damn whoa that's aquaman yo
that's insane his hair is cool
it is it's really good i'm such a fan
found out he was a biker like me i'm
like oh my god
we got everything account oh my god wait
is he your new hall pass
what are you doing i didn't realize it i
didn't realize he was on baywatch that's
crazy
so wait he so he got he landed game of
thrones and then he got paid
then he went broke again is that what
y'all know he laid he got he got game of
thrones
and then aquaman no he no he got game of
thrones
then he was on the show on netflix
um about vikings and he was the leader
of apple it was all apple
yeah he got paid on that and then he
landed aquaman and now he's like
super famous okay shout out see
you think you're a decent like a human
being till you get next to him and i
look good
i'm you look like you turned his eyes
[Laughter]
he looked like a turd with eyes next to
him guess what i look like a bucket of
[ __ ] next to that man
it'll make you real self-conscious how
about how tall is he every
i mean every bit as tall as i am and
just maybe like girthy
and just like his styles all dope well
he has like a really earthy stallion
like
he has like all these bracelets on and
it's kind of like barbaric
hippie oh yeah i see him kicking it with
like a lot of skateboarders that uh he's
like a dude
yeah built a skate ramp in his backyard
for his son
oh hell yeah i got to figure out what
his diet daughter
i think is jason what's your name it's
it's kind of like a meal it's kind of
like a rock
too like a lot a lot of it's genetics
man they're just born that way
okay yeah because he's like hawaiian and
uh he's samoan hawaiian like their
genetics
islanders are huge yeah so i don't have
those genetics yeah priests you and i
don't have those genetics
i got prison genetics yeah i do yeah
yeah you're right good for you that
boyfriend prison genetics prison
genetics they're [ __ ] with what you got
yeah yeah
yeah bro they just get get the homie on
your back and do some calf raises
yeah oh that's what possible he did in
prison for work
i put homies on his back
yeah all right shout out to jason momoa
jason tell me your diet bro
go ask him he'll be he's always off to
paying at the another good looking dude
chris hemsworth
also really big oh dude thor was he
fantastic
thor used to uh work out where i worked
out i saw him box one time
jesus christ dude crazy cardio for days
and how many rounds can fight fight did
like 10 rounds more rounds than i did
now at that time i was a professional
fighter yeah that's him right now
he's getting bigger he's playing hulk
hogan on netflix oh yeah i heard about
that yeah
that's him right now yeah playing hulk
by the way
what is is that oh that's a i'm tired
i'm curious
to see like how they're gonna do this
hulk hogan movie what do you mean
because it's okay when he had a great
career let's be honest
hulk hogan yeah yeah mount rushmore okay
but you know they canceled him
what they came to tim they didn't cancel
because they did because he said
it worked they took off oh really
or something yeah and they took it he
took they took everything from now did
they really
bro he he won that uh gawker thing
because they leaked a sex tape so he
sued gawker
he has like hundreds of millions of
dollars oh oh okay his daughter was a
singer wasn't
yeah brook hogan i'm saying back in the
day
she did a song she has to do that
right she didn't paul
here's what's crazy about that hogan
show is the wife and hulk hogan
[ __ ] hated each other and they were
gonna get a divorce
but then they found out that show got
green lit so they stayed together only
when the cameras were on
but when it shut off he would go
somewhere else so they just pretended
they were all together wow
yeah [ __ ] haiti there it is right
there let me hear that song it's a good
song i just played it
what does she do now she's oh he's still
wasn't she dating what a camera
we won the plastic cup boys or something
really really
i think that's what i heard last time
well remember the sun killed a guy
oh yeah do you watch so you don't want
him as your uber driver
let's see i see what you did there i see
what you did there i'm not gonna say
anything
she look every bit like hulk hogan
is she tall yeah yeah i mean just six
one
i bet they had to pay him a pretty penny
to do this about
us right yeah okay we got a chapel
[Music]
oh now i remember the song i don't know
i guess she's singing
she is she trying
it's like that genre of pop in the early
2000's you know okay she just
stopped singing wait did she's her
height because i don't believe
him oh dude i'm telling she's probably
a stallion big girl my mama 5 11.
hulk hogan is not six seven no he's not
he came to my fight he's ringside one of
my fights
and i was talking i looked down his feet
and his platforms on like this
he has them that's what floyd mayweather
wears yeah he has big platforms like
this
yeah what does she do now so did the
rocks do you see her graham
can we edit that she's probably still
making albums that's my guy but she's
wiped out
okay how many followers 333
okay god is good yeah yeah
it's good look at them you don't have
them look at the feet shut up
big toe cutest pretty lady she is yeah
she's pretty
she looks so much like her dad though
[Music]
i could look passionate like you can't
see me she's got a baby
and that's probably a niece oh baby
that's crunchy like nieces yeah
trust me i know i know a pregnant woman
oh her brother had a baby yeah
i looked past that hulk hogan face
i think i'll say anything is she still
making music chin scroll up
look what's that brook hogan thing i
think it's a book no scroll down no no
no no no no no no don't go on your
[ __ ] website
the website shows everything i don't
need brook hogan merch
scroll down i think it's our book bro
see that right there
this round oh it's a book yeah it's a
book bro i know
you have already found my new single yes
hit that [ __ ]
i was just going to do this oh so she's
still doing music love people i
figured it's what she was she was just
weird when people just stop
she was just in nashville she said on
that little location yeah why wouldn't
she still do music
nashville got some hidden talent you'll
see somebody
hey what happened wait what happened i
said why wouldn't she do music
no you know what come on where's the new
one
maybe it's just on the streaming and not
on a video i bought it
how about it look at nashville tennessee
it's called love
people yeah i typed that in nothing
happened
uh how would we stream it let me
love people touch my body does my body
look on the fire
one year ago
already yeah man
i'm thinking about getting a little what
are you thinking about i was thinking
about getting like a little uh what's it
called
brook hogan love people love people
god damn natasha mostly
oh he's right here right let's see oh
hit it chin
she going country he was in nashville so
i'm assuming
how many views one 591 views
it's not bad released
that's not bad that's not bad good alex
and
i found out 911 views yeah it's going
out for a second too
october october 21st
well she it must be new because she only
has 1.8 000 subscribers
yeah she's trying to do country isn't it
yeah she ain't nashville
it's not bad it's not hard it's not bad
i love her
yeah that's not bad at all she's
definitely trying to go country though
yeah good for her
bro country is is what's up right now
yeah yes
it's always been what's really dope i'm
about to start oh bro
our boy gateway our bro our
boy dearest rucker sang last night with
uh katy perry at the american museum you
hear it
your boy tear it up tear it up play it
chin
he teared up i teared up you turned up
he didn't turn up
for me tear it up shout out to baby it's
so good mm-hmm
you forget how [ __ ] good he is man oh
there it is
only love already more views than brooke
helga well she just started come on she
just started because it came out
this morning this is american music yeah
come on now she's trying
you forget how good katie how talented
katy perry is oh she's super excited oh
my god you forget
who's she dating oh orlando bloom this
had a baby
she had a baby like a few months ago
baby girl
shout out congratulations yeah she can
sing sing that
i think people forget because she makes
pop music yeah but she grew up singing
in a church
yeah which is like she's a pastor you're
singing in the church you got to [ __ ]
be on look here's our boy okay
oh wait till he hits it it's just is it
those two together
it's a different they're so good
together i love darius marilyn
my joke bomb hey dude dolphins make me
cry
all right and we all looked at each
other yep and he was like i'll see you
later man
there's the audience up top and that
traja p
henson p hunting she's called the host
killed it little action
a little action it was top question
she did well no no she did well she
could
you know who crushed it who crashed it
was the weekend
he did what are you saying because
weekend doesn't miss they have to get
creative
because there's no audience so he
performed on the la bridge with
fireworks
dude it was dope and then people are
worried about him because it looked like
he just had facial surgery
because he came out that's from his last
album after hours
he has that look right ella got a bro oh
there it is jen
yeah the l.a remember the weekend
blinding lights live on
uh yeah downtown you see it chin this
one here
no third one third one that one's uh
from 2020
vmas two months ago it was two months
ago i can't believe they don't have it
on there but that
he that's him in the math there yeah
how's him winning right here how did
justin bieber uh do what he's performing
bieber don't miss
come on oh travis barker and uh machine
gun kelly performed
oh did that oh yeah megan fox uh
presented him
yeah they killed it oh what did she say
was she like this is my baby this is my
boo now she's just very casual you know
brian austin green's like [ __ ]
yeah let me bring up travis parker and
uh machine gun kelly chen
they're two of my faves they killed my
last album you started listening to
machine gun kelly right yeah
you can tell it's very blink 182-ish oh
this is them
is it yep it's performance
here yeah she killed it exactly
tired of y'all with this extras talk let
me hear how um uh megan introduced him
look at how beautiful she is oh she's
such a baddie
is she doing a lot of movies once in a
lifetime yeah
i think so we've all been under his
spell since his debut in 2012.
performing bloody valentine and my ex's
best friend joined by travis barkley
x's best one kelly she killed me oh
i'd be not she's like my boo yeah say
your boo
like my man no she had to keep it
professional i like that i want a badass
[Music]
is that not good but that's a lot of pop
punk
solos oh no yeah a lot of power chords
yeah
boy he's had a big 20 20. good for him
now he's not feeling this i'm trying to
i'm i'm trying to be
but bring off traffic i'm trying to look
for travis
have you seen uh mgk's girlfriend right
before uh megan fox
she's bad too summer rae oh summer hell
yeah she's the only fan
does she have only fans talking about
the model right yeah so yes i'm alright
she's like all these followers on
instagram did we run into her blue jam
no it was not you different black guy
sorry
yeah she's super 25 million people yeah
i'm like right there come on man i would
say
who who's back oh she don't have her
making fans we was begging her to make
one i'm sorry i probably
who's weak who's making her fans me and
people who do you think's hotter her
megan fox she's more my speed her
i think they're like different types of
horses man we should protect a pole and
say who's hot is summer rae
or megan fox and i guarantee you
everyone
we on the same page look at this it's
the reason why she has 25 million
followers and she doesn't do anything
but how many does megan fox off is she
even on if i'm gonna bounce creative
like
just 25 million followers point five
what her backup account has like two
three million followers yep they have a
bet why she got a backup account come on
just support stuff
that's not like come on more fun she
doesn't want on her official account i
guess 9.9
they're both saucy but i'd say some are
ready
some are really easy i love megan [ __ ]
so like what about megan fox and
transformers hood of the car
versus summer right now i know because
that's more i think of it accurate i
wonder who makes one
honey megan fox looks good right now
somewhere on her face
yes i'd say megan fox's face is better
uh when she came out with that little
tattoo right here i was like this is the
woman of my dreams
summer rae no more mega [ __ ] me she had
that little tattoo how old is she
who megan fox uh i want to say like
late 30s now yeah for sure late 30s 34
34
okay oh we're only a year apart huh oh
mid 30s then yeah
oh yeah she's a baddie now go back to
summary one more time so i can just
so i can end on that i would say summer
right now megan fox
when she first came out what but you
gotta understand summer rape thing was
bad
she was like yeah summer is younger than
i am some no way really yeah she's like
maybe a year or two younger than me okay
wait what oh i'd say some ray all day
matter of fact thank you bro
look at that that's more of my speed oh
look at that bikini chin
go that bikini video one time let me see
that that's fine yeah let me just see
that
photoshop where though talk that talk
shop where though
come on bro and she playing bryson
tiller next to you
look at that workout yeah she first team
all bad yeah
matter of fact this pokemon go she's
walking on that i was looking at it
what is happening megan fox no
no how dare you she is
cheeked up come on man
you should see uh summer's mom summer's
mom's got a body on her too how does she
uh i don't know how old her mom is what
is she famous from just being a fine
child for me
yeah she's like one of those like
instagram girls she comes from uh
last time i like looked up her and her
family because i was like
goddamn her and her mom both of her
parents are bodybuilders and so she just
has amazing genetics
she posted up like workout videos when
she was like 19 years old and blew the
[ __ ] up
damn she's sexy bro that's how bad you
are you have 25.5
she said guys look at this unicorn and
my butt
wow good for her man all right what else
you got chin
all right let me know what the [ __ ] god
dawg look at the one the jeans
jeans this one's over this game set
match that's gay that's it this is
megan fox what
how are you liking that she's so funny
you liking that right
i mean look at you look at you
her face looks a little different in
these pictures as i'm saying but i would
yeah i choose summer
like i said i i choose i'm the only one
that chooses like i could choose up but
i think she's
prettier right now but when megan [ __ ]
[ __ ] uh
i think summer rae all day twice on
sunday thank you megan fox when she was
on like two and a half men
matter of fact she's not just buying
[ __ ] right now you can [ __ ] someone i
know
no she looks great summer rae i don't
care you can go back then she'll still
be fine
you talking about megan fox and her
prime give it some time for the point
wait let me remember hold on she looks a
little too young here are you
serious yeah she was smoking long tits
look at the long ones up top see how
they're long they're a little droopy
yeah
real long it like it looked like they
had a long day uh uh summer rae all day
but summer are you now first lingard fox
has never not looked good
neither someone right thank you what
what are we missing here people
and somebody hasn't reached their prime
23. there's megan fox
she has though she's thirty-five oh
everybody that's the baddest you gonna
see megan fox
unless you're like a j lois like
transformers megan fox the first one was
the best megan fox i think and she still
doesn't beat summer rae i agree mel
true put we got the polls set up we have
the poll it's
only been up for two minutes it's like
kind of back and forth so far
it's 41 percent summer rae 59 megan fox
i do see also true yeah like she's
well known i put photos for them to
reference oh type movement
that's good time okay i'm good we need
to give them some sort of contrast
don't miss out okay yeah i love that
what else you got jen
uh just one more in your hometown well
you're aurora right aurora colorado
born and raised boy so they just opened
up their very first in and out
i didn't think they would be it would
take this long but first in and out and
it was like 14 hour wait 14 hours for
people to figure out that they're
overrated yeah
wait it's all right i know it's
overrated but then how about those skies
in aurora that was kind of oh
that's beautiful it's nice out there yep
yeah get the phone look at that crap
i wouldn't know it's over it's insane
never bro for the animal fries
bye nothing bye listen the only thing
i'm waiting 14 hours for is summer rae
i think summer rae did like a meet and
greet recently with your boy brian
ortega
oh really yeah i saw something like that
um
meet and greet yeah yeah jim out here
california
brian ortega he's a mercy fighter
handsome devil
don't let him around your girl how about
the guy that uh
won this weekend you said such a beast
and we was waiting for the fight we was
all tired
oh that guy i remember he shaved his
entire head off
yeah the last fight what's the uh
brazilian story you're talking about
brittany yeah who's got that
margarita figurine yeah beast the guy
who models is alan jovan
joe band model he's versa what used to
be with versace
wasasu now brian was more of a dying
piece when his head was in shape
he had that tarzan look to him when he
had him you look great with long hair
oh damn diamond piece hell yeah yeah you
should don't let me get along here you
shaved it made a mistake
that's all right i'm gonna really like
i'm gonna try to go don't let me get
long hair i'm gonna grow long hair i'm
gonna do it i'm serious i'm a little
like my friend puerto rican johnny
i'm gonna go all the way down oh my god
long hair how about that we saw that one
dude in uh
dallas that had like the leo hair oh
yeah yeah yeah the kodak black
like lisa simpson dreads yeah that's
what they do
he was in the corner uh princess right
we were hanging out we're hanging out
princess is just
all nervous yeah remember the guy who
justin was like no trustees dude
i don't remember seeing that guy oh man
where were you
oh eating hot chicken that's fair that
hot chicken did make me delirious though
they [ __ ] my night up but you just got
the hot you got the hat too
and i was fine with the hot it was the
[ __ ] the hot one
when i ordered it she said honey who
that for yeah
[Laughter]
i said me michelin you sure you want to
do this i said pretty sure
yeah y'all did that salute to y'all yeah
the hot was like the
perfect like taste that one tasted good
and it tasted good
it was tasty but that [ __ ] triple x
summer rae i think is going to beat
megan fox but as of right now
she is at 47 percent for summer rae 53
for me how many votes though
uh it's 433 for summer ray 498 for megan
fox i think summer rae
is going to beat her out give it a
couple hours 434 can i about to place my
vote
okay good for you uh get that voted all
right this friday
thick boy black friday is happening
we got this tie-dye hoodie another
tie-dye hoodie
two tie-dye thick boys shirts we got
women's uh
tights thick girl tights thick girls
shorts dropping
we got the short sleeve hoodies dropping
you see me riding my bike on all the
time
my favorite hoodies we got two new dope
patchwork
thick boy bike club hats dropping and i
think the site's 40
off too that's for black friday this
friday
early in the morning that [ __ ] is going
on sale think boy.com
black friday is here and then next time
this cruise on tour
is in boise idaho there's 20 tickets
left one theater one night only in boise
idaho with this squad
december 5th and then west palm beach
just announced tickets going fast
west palm beach it's the west palm beach
improv there
december 31st through january 2nd
bring in the new year get rid of 2020
with this crew we're going to be [ __ ]
uh chairings with whiskey
all right so come on down to west palm
beach improv december 31st through
january 2nd me and the crew will be
there
tfatk.com for tickets thickboy.com the
biggest sale
ever for your thick ass what's cracking
this weekend me malik b
we're going to be at tempe turner
michael turner yeah michael turner
he's hosting so shout out to him tempe
was it friday saturday sunday friday
saturday sunday
uh tickets are on sale lac.com
also go ahead and get that merch love is
tight love is tight
dog uh malik is you got your [ __ ]
together
oh yeah we're getting our [ __ ] together
this week
this week friday yeah the black friday
you get all that sauce that you want you
know you two near me not to hear me
you know what i mean don't get lost in
the soil store
dot com no it's malik drip.com
malikdrip.com just type that in is that
[ __ ] ready to go yeah we ready to go we
ain't got it going for you yeah we
we we uh
are such a funny duo yeah they are they
just crack with you
i love j arguments maybe taxing non-stop
i know
how about how about y'all like listen
and this is the thing that tripped me
out you know
me and jay love sports but you went to
brennan for
unbiased opinion no because what i'm
saying is it's like
like for for god like me that's newer to
sports and i'm hearing it your way
it just seems like it's a circle there's
no they always
do it in circles they go you guys going
i don't have a dog in the fight i'm not
a
i'm not balls deep in lebron or michael
i like both of them so it's like it's
just outside of person so like me
listening to it i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you saying so like he
just has an unbiased opinion so it's
he just explains it from a broader
standpoint that's the reason why i say
that all right
lakers again like i said you've never
you've never really settled it
i did settle don't never settle it
they'll never sound every time we're on
the road you guys argue about jordan and
uh lebron
yeah i think i think but you who brought
it up put the rolex down
who brought it up you brought it up
right uh he brought it up
yes what you doing over there chin jelly
roll merch i'm just looking at the old
joe coy oh yeah it's dope don't worry
yeah all right
all right that's it thickboy.com black
friday blackest friday ever
thickboy.com boise see it december 5th
new year's west palm beach let's ride
dfatk.com
we out